I want to make sure I remind everyone
that this Wednesday this coming
Wednesday at 10 o'clock p.m. not our
usual time 10 o'clock p.m. we're gonna
air our next prime time travel special
it's called Conan in Italy yes here's
the deal I I went to Italy and I took
someone who works here at the show he's
an associate producer who's been with me
for a very very long time his name is
Jordan shlonsky Jordan is from a polish
family on Long Island but he always acts
like he's from Italy and that's not a
bit or a joke or anything he really does
just act like he's from Italy and Lords
it over all of us so I figured it was
time to take Jordan to Italy and just
put his money where his mouth is the
entire trip I promised you the entire
trip which took like five days we went
all over the boot of Italy the entire
trip was one long freak show here's just
a few just a few highlights take a look
you like we could take a photo here why
would you want to photo with anybody
else in it you only take photos by
yourself cuz you only have one
expression
you look like you're chasing us with
Keanu Reeves in the matrix say mr.
Anderson you disappoint me
I could get out and push it I think the
battery's dead what are you gonna do oh
yeah oh yeah she's fantastic
I think you drank the whole thing you
were supposed to spill this some of it
out why well you see if you become
intoxicated you won't be able to add it
watch this it's a magic trick I learned
in alcoholism school what I would like
to do is go very deep into the woods and
once we are very very deep in the woods
boy I would like Louise Wally to kill my
friend pumpkin spice latte Louise early
in the cafe latte comes Uka Uka Uka Uka
yeah yeah
yeah it's a lot of fun
you